no
[Música]
hola
hoy les vengo a hacer una pregunta
ustedes conocen a alguien a quien parece
que todo le sale bien esa gente que de
repente desde niños dicen es que yo voy
a hacer un cantante famoso y nadie les
cree y de repente son un cantante famoso
o esa gente que decide que va a
emprender un negocio y nadie le crea
dice una vez que dice que da por un
restaurante y de repente pone un
restaurante y eso es un éxito pues esa
es la pregunta que nos hacemos todos que
hizo esa persona para lograr lo que
quería es acaso suerte es acaso talento
es acaso trabajo que es lo que hace que
las personas sean exitosas qué es lo que
hace que lo que uno se proponga lo logre
yo les quiero agregar una historia hace
unos 15 años conocí a un chico que se
llamaba isac isaac era baterista en una
banda un tipo súper popular en querétaro
tocaba en bares le abría conciertos
artistas estaban todas partes llegaba a
los antros y les abrían las cadenas esa
era mi definición del éxito en aquel
entonces yo les pregunté hoy isaac oye
cómo le haces para ser tan bueno y me
dice miranda en esta vida hay dos tipos
de personas que tienen éxito la gente
que tiene talento y la gente que es muy
necia y yo soy muy necio porque en
realidad no soy tan buen baterista
yo trabajo más que nadie yo practico más
que nadie yo toco más puertas que nadie
yo siempre estoy cuando me necesite y
esta lección ha dado vueltas en mi
cabeza desde hace 15 años estudio
pensaba si quiero lograr esto tengo que
ser muy talentosa o tengo que ser muy
mesia y resulta que no soy ninguna de
las dos
es para mí hay una tercera opción que es
tener un buen plan entonces yo les
quiero platicar sobre el poder de los
planes y el poder que los planes tienen
para cambiar sus vidas y ayudarlos a
cumplir sus objetivos yo soy una firme
creyente de que si tú tienes claro qué
es lo que quieres qué es lo que tienes
que hacer cómo lo tienes que hacer lo
vas a lograr una de las cosas como más
comunes con las que nos encontramos es
que la gente no lo logra y
constantemente está culpando a todo
mundo así es que nadie las oportunidades
es que saben que ese local está maldito
no es que mi mamá no me apoyo entonces
hay como un montón de pretextos por los
cuales la gente dice porque no logró lo
que quería porque no acabó la
universidad porque no no sé se volvió
famoso la realidad es que siete de cada
diez empresas en méxico fracasan en sus
primeros dos años de vida
por qué es esto bueno de acuerdo a estas
cifras es por falta de un diagnóstico
porque se les acabó el dinero porque
ocurrió algo que no esperaban porque no
tenían el talento necesario porque no
supieron colocar sus productos porque no
subieron posicionarse para mí todo eso
suena a que no tenían un plan se
aventaron a la marcha o no pero este no
previeron todo lo que podía pasar todas
las cosas que están alrededor no
midieron los riesgos no calcularon el
dinero no contrataron a la gente
adecuada
nunca escribieron que era lo que tenía
que hacer
entonces yo les voy a compartir un
método sencillo que a mí me ha
funcionado para hacer un plan exitoso lo
que decir que es una regla quiere decir
que es una forma de hacer las cosas la
primera es
y este es un capricho personal pero es
apunta para las estrellas si vas a hacer
algo planea pon tu objetivo en lo más
alto posible apunta a las estrellas
busca ser el mejor el más grande lo más
difícil que puedas hacer yo escucho la
historia de la de la ponente anterior y
piensas ella estaba apuntando a las
estrellas y para eso tienes que ser
súper claro en lo que quieras la
claridad es poder tienes que ser
específico en lo que quieras que tu
objetivo sea ser millonario no es un
objetivo es muy diferente decir quiero
ser millonario decir quiero ser un
arquitecto exitoso que construye casas y
con eso gana mucho dinero tienes que ser
específico en lo que deseas en la medida
en la que lo tengas vas a poder
construir un plan para lograrlo la
segunda
no tengas un objetivo ve
una vez que tienes un objetivo ve dejas
de trabajar por el objetivo si tú dices
constantemente yo quiero ser un gran
empresario
y viajar por el mundo tener una empresa
transnacional pero si eso no funciona me
conformaría con ser el gerente de una
gran empresa sabes que vas a hacer el
gerente porque porque casi siempre el
objetivo es mucho más fácil que el
objetivo a la grandeza es mucho más
complicada que las empresas
yo soy un plan freak
los que me conocen lo saben mis amigos
lo saben mi equipo lo sabe mis clientes
lo saben mi novio lo sabe yo lo voy a
una fiesta si no sé dónde es a qué hora
es que van a dar de comer quiénes van a
ir y sobre todo y especialmente que me
tengo que poner
trato de tener
el mayor control del ambiente que me
rodea si bien hay factores externos que
pueden contribuir cuando tuvo planeas y
previos los factores externos casi
siempre funcionan
entonces
nosotros tenemos una empresa de
consultoría política trabajamos en
digital y básicamente una parte
importante de nuestro trabajo es la
producción hacemos producción de tele y
producción
digamos para redes vídeos canciones y
videoclips etcétera cuando hacemos estas
producciones hacemos una ficha de
planeación bastante sofisticada pero a
la vez bastante simple que se ve algo
así que tiene básicamente que vamos a
hacer donde lo vamos a hacer y cómo lo
vamos a hacer cuál es el objetivo cuál
es el mensaje que queremos comunicar qué
segmento va a llevar el minuto a minuto
que lo va a editar quién va a ser la
corrección de color cuándo se va a
publicar y demás y entonces hacemos
estas fichas y se las entregamos a los
clientes para definir si los vamos a
hacer o no y un día un cliente le dijo
al equipo hoy es es que a mí no me
mandes esas fichas este a mi mandame un
mensaje con lo que quieres hacer y con
eso suficiente entonces el equipo llegó
súper feliz porque pues claramente esto
es mucho trabajo si andrea ya no tenemos
que hacer las fichas que queren seguimos
haciendo las fichas porque porque cuando
tú escribes un plan te ayuda a abstraer
tu pensamiento cuando tú redacta el
documento con tus objetivos te ayuda a
tener claridad de qué es lo que quieres
cuáles son qué vas a seguir y te ayuda a
entrenar tu mente a tomar decisiones de
forma estratégica esa gente que vive así
a las vivas y da dios proveerá este a
veces tiene mucha suerte no conozco
muchos si tú escribes tu plan es mucho
más probable que lo tengas claro y que
lo puedas lograr
que sigue cuando hay que empezar a hacer
un plan para hacer algo
la persona que inspiró esta platina la
conocí hace un par de meses un tipo de
verdad brillante fuera del lugar tipo
guapo joven más o menos 30 años que
trabaja en política y me dice con toda
seguridad
andreas yo quiero ser presidente de
méxico y excelente es un gran plan este
yo creo que méxico debe tener esto y
esto y me empezaba a contar todo lo que
él veía y que méxico tenía que cambiar
de esta manera y que teníamos que vivir
de esta otra manera y que los políticos
actuales y demás y entonces yo lo tuve
rápido el dije ok pero cuál es tu plan y
rápido se justifica dice bueno no
todavía no tengo un plan ya tengo 30
años y esto es como dentro de 10 ó 15
años
ahorita estoy trabajando en este trabajo
pero yo voy a trabajar mucho y lo quiero
mucho y es entonces cuando el tiempo sea
el correcto comenzaré a trabajar
y entonces yo me preguntaba si este tipo
tiene tan claro lo que quiere
porque no está haciendo nada para
lograrlo
entonces dices que tienes que ya empezar
a trabajar en lo que quieres y sé cómo
que el ego qué habilidades tienes que
desarrollar
quién es con quién te tienes que
relacionar qué es lo que tienes que
estar haciendo ahora dentro de 15 años
qué quieres que la gente hable de ti vas
a hacer una fundación vas a escribir un
libro vas a estudiar una maestría te
tienes que preguntar hoy qué es lo que
estás haciendo hoy para estar donde
quieres estar mañana el plan para llegar
a tu objetivo lo tienes que empezar en
cuanto defines tu objetivo y hay gente
que lo tiene claro desde que es bien
chiquititos hay gentes que dicen desde
los 8 años yo quiero ser mago ok empieza
este entonces nunca nunca es demasiado
pronto
la otra la siguiente no les va a gustar
porque les tengo que decir que la
sociedad les ha mentido
este pensamiento millennial y todos
estos libros de emprendimiento nos han
mentido nos han hecho creer que si
tienes una buena idea y húngaras tienes
todo lo que se necesita para ser bill
gates
cosa que no es cierto todos los días
estamos leyendo la nueva empresa
unicornio de un chavito en el silicon
valley o en algún lugar del mundo que
tuvo una gran idea con la pega en un año
y se hace millonario saben porque eso es
noticia
porque casi nunca pasa nunca sale en las
noticias hoy este señor se vuelve a
subir al camión porque porque eso es
común eso pasa todo el tiempo que
alguien llegue de esa manera en tan
corto tiempo es bastante extraño la
realidad es que uno tiene que trabajar
muy duro
el libro de players dice que para
convertirte en un experto calculan que
más o menos debiste haber invertido
alrededor de 10.000 horas de
profesionalización
y si yo sé que eso no es tan bonito
pensar que eso qué quieres te va a tomar
tantos años llegar a obtenerlo
y te gustaría pensar que quizá hay un
atajo para llegar más rápido para hacer
el nuevo mark zuckerberg de los de los
negocios o el nuevo coma moto de la
política hay acaso un atajo yo creo que
sí cuando yo empecé a trabajar
seriamente en política empecé en una
campaña de alcalde y ya hacíamos digital
ya más o menos había un consenso en que
las redes sociales iban a ser
importantes fueron tan importantes pero
ya había un consenso de que hacia allá
íbamos era la primera vez que yo
participaba en una junta de toma de
decisiones con senadores y ex
gobernadores y pues yo era
la única mujer
joven 20 22 años quizá no eran muy
populares el joven y mujer hace 8 años
entonces mucho me bueno sigue sin ser
popular hoy en día entonces ellos se
referían a mí de alguna forma despectiva
como la niña de las redes entonces era
de asia háblele a la niño de las redes
oye que el candidato no sé qué decir la
niña de las redes y me excluían de la
toma de decisiones importantes y yo
sabía que si no estaba en la toma de
decisiones importante yo no iba a dar el
siguiente paso en mi carrera entonces si
yo quería acortar el tiempo que me iba a
tomar estar en esa toma de decisiones
tenía que trabajar el doble que ellos
entonces yo me despertaba primero me
dormía el último todo el tiempo estaba
preparando estaba estudiando estaba
leyendo están escribiendo documentos me
puse como objetivo que a cada problema
que en la campaña se planteara yo iba a
tener una solución digital o un alterno
una propuesta digital para atender ese
problema entonces
el tiempo pasó la historia se contó y al
final la campaña se ganó
y nosotros seguimos trabajando vamos a
hacer campañas nacionales ahora hay que
trabajar
muy duro te tienes que levantar muy
temprano tienes que hacer más que los
demás tienes que prepararte más que los
demás porque no creas que tú eres el
único con esa idea seguramente alguien
también ya lo pensó y lo que tienes que
preguntar es si ese que también ya lo
pensó no se está levantando más temprano
que tú
y luego qué pasó sigue y este para mí es
súper importante porque mi empresa
son casi puros millennials la edad
promedio son entre 23 y 24 años entonces
además pues los problemas cotidianos de
trabajar en política pues uno trabaja
con un montón de jóvenes que están
encontrando en su personalidad y
definiendo su rumbo en la vida y yo veo
constantemente gente fracasar
en perseguir sus objetivos son lograr
sus objetivos porque no planearon una
cosa que es súper importante
cuáles son los sacrificios que tengo que
hacer para llegar a donde quiero llegar
escucho siempre gente diciendo cosas
como si yo quería ser super famoso y
viajar por el mundo pero nunca pensé que
iba a estar tanto tiempo separado de mi
familia si yo quería ser un emprendedor
exitoso pero nunca pensé que iba a tener
que trabajar dos turnos para lograrlo
tienes que en tu plan tener claro qué
sacrificios vas a hacer y si estás
dispuesto a hacerlo para mí la vida es
como una rueda de la fortuna y cada
carrito es un aspecto de la vida la
familia los amigos el trabajo y aunque
esté de moda el balance es bien
complicado y a veces unos carritos están
arriba ya veces otros carritos están
abajo la buena noticia es que casi
siempre puedes tú elegir qué carritos
están arriba y que carritos están abajo
en mi experiencia no científica
y comprobado en mi oficina es que
una de cada diez ocurrencias salen bien
nueve de cada diez cosas planeadas salen
bien
y debe ser increíble tener un golpe de
suerte y de repente pegarle algo y tener
un montón de éxito a mí eso no me ha
pasado pero lo que sí les puedo decir es
que cuando planeas algo trabajas muy
duro
tienes un plan de haces de la gente
adecuada entiendes qué es lo que se
tiene que hacer cuando lo logras se
siente muy bien y te llena de
satisfacción entonces
en resumen estos son los siete pasos que
yo les comparto para hacer un buen plan
primero apunta a las estrellas segundo
no tengas un plan b no tengas un
objetivo b
escribe tu plan redacta lo empieza
cuanto antes
utiliza los short cuts que están
disponibles reconoce los sacrificios que
tienes que hacer y por último trabaja
más duro que nadie hoy les puedo decir
que yo sigo siendo la niña de las redes
énfasis en la
la niña de las redes grass
[Aplausos]
[Música]